it's the holiday season and today i'm
going to tell you how you can buy your
very own time machine that doubles as a
teacher a lifelong hobby and possibly a
profitable career and by the way it
costs under 50
today we're going into the impossible
with the gift that transformed me from a
nerdy introverted pimple-faced kid to a
professor of physics it changed my life
forever and today i'll give you tips to
do the same for the kid in your life too
[Music]
on this channel i aspire to inspire you
to always be curious abc by sharing ways
to stoke imagination with lessons from
the greatest minds in history and from
the present and speaking of presents
it's the holiday season and in today's
special holiday edition is dedicated
for you to find the perfect choice for a
gift for the curious kid in your life in
many previous videos i've discussed the
bicep astronomical telescope and my
exploits at the south pole the very
bottom of the world bicep is actually a
very simple refracting telescope it uses
lenses and instead of focusing light on
your eyes as you would with a small
optical telescope like this
it focused onto very sensitive super
conducting transition edge sensor
bolometer detectors but half the fun of
doing bicep is getting to go to the
south pole
it's the most remote place on earth and
you can only reach it for a tiny window
in the year
and while you're there you might be
surprised to find all these astronomers
congregating around without any
astronomical objects whatsoever to look
at except for two
the sun and the moon those are the only
two objects visible during the
summertime season which lasts from
approximately december 21st to march
21st at the south pole
out of phase with the northern
hemisphere seasons and during that
daytime a single day the sun is above
the horizon 24 7. of course you can't
really tell the days are passing except
if you note the path the circular arc
path that the sun and the moon mouth
make the moon takes a full month to get
around in its orbit around the earth and
so you can actually use the moon as a
sort of crude time keeping device its
phase and its position can help the poor
astronomers stranded there such as
myself
to actually observe the passage of time
i've spent about a month or so at the
south pole and i've been there twice
it's been a fascinating journey to get
from san diego down to the bottom of the
world and it's fascinating to note that
the very object that took me there was
the moon the moon guided me on a direct
path from being a child fascinated with
the sky to the cosmology career that i
enjoy today and today i'm going to take
you on a journey along with me of
curiosity and discovery back to when i
was an unpopular pimple-faced kid in
upstate new york
it all began in dobbs ferry new york
4 a.m the middle of summer 1984.
are you kidding me i left the lights on
again
but wait a second the light was off
the light
shining into my bedroom was coming from
outside my room
in fact it was coming from the heavens
above
it was the moon it was plump it was full
it was low on the horizon
as sun was preparing to rise in the east
the moon was setting in the west but the
moon was not alone
it was brighter than any street light
and yet its companion nearby to it
was bigger apparently than any star i've
ever seen
and it was rivaling the moon in every
attempt at brightness
it looked like a mesmerizingly bright
star
but it couldn't be a star it had to be a
plane maybe it was american airlines
flight 137 on its way somewhere exotic
because what kind of star could rival
the brightness of the moon
i was 13 years old and i had never seen
anything like it for the next few nights
i watched the moon and its brilliant
companion arc across the humid indian
summer skies over westchester county
i was perplexed and mesmerized
i simply had to find out more about the
celestial companion to the brilliant and
beautiful moon
now this being 1984 google was about 14
years in the future i had no desire nor
patience to wait that long to find out
what was going on in the skies above
dobbs ferry
back then i had no other choice but to
wait until the sunday new york times
came out with a section called cosmos
and in the cosmos section were
depictions of what the celestial sites
above us the zodiac the planets and and
so forth would be visible from the new
york city area and back then i was an
altar boy in the catholic church
so after church services ended i grabbed
sunday's new york times paper and i was
hit with a revelation more exhilarating
than any church sermon i'd ever heard
the star i thought i observed the star i
thought i discovered
the plane that wasn't ever moving was
not a star it was not a plane it was the
planet jupiter
but how is that possible how could you
see an actual planet without a telescope
or a spaceship how could another world
be visible to my naked eyes
now
it was a short leap to think about what
brilliant illuminations one could see if
i had a telescope i just had to get one
but given my family's meager means
finding a spare 50 bucks for the
cheapest spy glass i could get my hands
on would be a challenge
fortunately in 1984 i had had a summer
job stocking shelves at the venice deli
in dobbs ferry making a cool
3.35 cents for each of the four hours of
hard labor i put in each week
it was going to take quite a while six
weeks at least
to earn enough money to buy a telescope
on my own
by then summer would be long over i'd be
back at school and i wouldn't have any
time to use the telescope
and possibly for all i knew the
brilliant planet jupiter would have
disappeared from the sky
how could i possibly obtain the magical
tool to slag my astronomical thirst to
know more about the cosmos
well
i was lucky i had a very generous
three-letter funding agency
that has traditionally been the first
funding agency of choice for many many
young budding scientists
instead of considering a life of crime
with the local branch of the soprano
crime family i was a little bit too
pudgy to gain entry into them anyway
never had the makings of a varsity
athlete i
beseeched
the three-letter funding agency
not the nsf not the doe not the dod
but the mom my mother barbara
my mom instantly saw that i was putting
in a little bit of my own due diligence
trying to earn money to earn the right
to have this telescope but also that she
could supplement
and boost my curiosity far beyond any
other present one could imagine
and so she generously supplemented my
scrimpings and gave me a generous grant
soon i became the principal investigator
the pi
over my very own two inch diameter
refracting telescope with adjustable
magnification eyepiece as soon as i got
my hands on the telescope
night couldn't come quickly enough after
battling some cloudy late summer haze i
was able to turn the tiny little
telescope heavenward and just put it in
a place in the middle of the street
for just long enough to avoid getting
run over by passing cars i was addicted
every single night i would take the
telescope out even if it was cloudy
within hours that very first night i saw
jupiter's moons a retinue of four
brilliant little dots surrounding the
king of the planets like a heavyweight
boxer and his jostling entourage heading
towards the ring just like that i had
quadrupled the number of moons i had
seen in my life
later that night i saw the highest
mountains and deepest craters on the
moon's surface
it was overwhelming then i turned my
telescope to the milky way
looking at colorful stars of near
infinite variety
soon i discovered diaphanous deep sky
objects such as nebulae and galaxies
they came into crisp focus but this
telescope did more than just make me an
observer of the heavens i became a
celestial evangelist trying mostly in
vain to convince others
of the wonders of the heavens maybe even
just to look up most of us spend our
lives nowadays looking down on our
phones
barely looking up above the horizon
try it for yourself see how
uncomfortable you feel looking at a 45
degree angle let alone a 90 degree angle
it's very unusual for us nowadays and
even back then it wasn't so common i'd
wait for people walking down my street
to take a peek and i would show them
these wonderful sites
and showing the public the visual
delights with my telescopes was a little
bit of a mixed bag
some people got it but many didn't
someone asked me can we look at your
neighbor girl again or worse do you mean
that little smudge in the eyepiece oh
that's it but when i needed some extra
convincing i'd call in the ringer
saturn
even the most jaded video game addict
was left slack jawed after glimpsing the
magnificently disked cream-colored world
we call saturn it has its own moons too
including titan an enormous almost
earth-sized moon my telescope became my
time machine
it took me on a ride to other worldly
vistas and it can do the same for you
the telescope had a secondary ancillary
benefit
it caused me to want to investigate to
learn more about the objects i was
seeing each night so during the day
i would examine these objects not on the
internet which didn't exist yet
but in books magazines and anything
printed i could get my hands on it was
quite difficult i needed more than what
i could get from the new york times once
a week so i devoured all the
astronomical media i could ever find and
scare the socks off some poor librarian
i subscribed to astronomy magazine for
about 20 bucks a year that was most of
my savings for my week's worth of work
and i'm still delighted to have
contributed to about two or three
articles in astronomy magazine oh those
many years later as a professional
astronomer
i also engaged in real research
keeping a very simple log book just a
marble notebook with a pencil attached
to it by a rubber band so that my older
brother wouldn't steal it from me and i
would write down and sketch out the
images that i was seeing through the
telescope certainly ccd cameras were
years in the future and would not be
affordable of some of my modest means
so instead i had to sketch it and that
brought out fine details details i
wanted to learn more about
so
the more i learned the more precious
these science became to me and
especially so when i read about them in
the bible
all right not the actual bible rather it
was the peterson field guide to the
stars and planets and it became my
celestial scripture
i'd read the guide all day anxiously
awaiting nightfall a pimple-faced astro
dracula craving the quiet shelter of the
night sky
i still have my original copy of the
peterson guide it's in my office at uc
san diego and it proudly bears the
autograph of its author jay pasikov
professor of astronomy at williams
college i've been delighted to visit jay
and give lectures at williams college
and for him to come here to uc san diego
none of that would have been possible if
i didn't discover
the night sky yes that's all it counts
it became a time machine
as well
as being a social engineering machine to
get to know some of the most celestial
of all intellects on earth
even now when i read the book when i
leap through it any night of the year
the scent of the pages
their crisp colors it takes me back to
being a 13 year old again yet another
form of time travel
now the guide also contained extensive
scientific discussions of the planets
and it showed me how to observe them
for each planet there was a brief
description of how the great and first
optical astronomer to use a telescope
galileo galilei how he perceived it when
he looked through his own arm-length
spyglass 400-plus years earlier
eventually galileo's observations led
him to believe that copernicus not
aristotle or ptolemy were right
the sun not the earth was the center of
the universe
he couldn't keep that discovery to
himself and of course he wrote
eventually wrote the dialogue the
dialogue on the two world systems
aristotelianism parapatheticism and of
course copernicanism and i am overjoyed
that another byproduct of my early
exploits into astronomy has now paid
dividends 40 years later almost and
that's that i am will fl my friends
carlo ravelli luccio picharillo fabiola
giannatti jim gates and frank wilczyk
recording the first ever audiobook
version of the dialogue stay tuned to
this channel for more information about
that wonderful project coming soon now
when i
learned after reading about galileo's
descriptions of the discoveries that he
made centuries earlier he had done the
exact same thing i had done turned it to
the brightest things in the sky
jupiter saturn he didn't turn into the
sun but the moons of jupiter were his
timepieces his celestial diamonds
i had done the same thing as the great
galileo now of course it wasn't that i
was originating these discoveries of
course he made them hundreds of years
earlier but i had the exact same
visceral experience i'm convinced that
the great maestro did as well
and of course it was cute that there was
a connection between the maestro and
myself that we were both supported in
some sense by venetian patrons his the
doge and senate of venice and mine the
venice delhi and i wanted to emulate
galileo in every way possible
except for that final last chapter of
home imprisonment and semi-threats of
being tortured
let's avoid that and even at that time
in 1984 galileo had never been even
issued a formal apology he still hasn't
been pardoned by the catholic church
but at least in the late 80s early 90s
uh pope john paul did issue a statement
that he was correct if not actually
pardoning him working on the dialogue
with these phenomenal educators frank
fabiola carlo luccio and jim gates
working with them really reminds me of
what the word educate really means
the word educate comes from the latin
phrase educare
i think fabiola can do a better job
pronouncing it than i can
what that word means to bring out of not
to pour into
we educators are always searching for
ways to enhance the learning process
to make it more visceral more resonant
with our students in order to bring out
the best within them imagine if you
could replicate the thrill the visceral
excitement that the physicists at the
large hadron collider including fabiola
felt when they discovered the higgs
boson particle in 2012. you actually
didn't have a single discovery event
but you couldn't even do that unless you
happen to have a spare 10 billion
dollars or so lying around and then you
could roll your own lhc
but i doubt that's true for you
certainly wasn't true for me
and yet for fifty dollars you can get
your own telescope and you yourself can
replicate the feeling of discovery
that galileo felt over 400 years ago
how often is that possible in science
it's a very rare experience to have a
connection in history between the first
discoverer of something and a student
and best of all if you do that if you go
out and buy a telescope
for you or for your own children
you and i can be connected as well
feeling the same feelings that i felt
which is what i strive for in
communicating the deep impact that
astronomy has had on me and we'll share
it as two astronomers it doesn't matter
if you're professional or not
once you unlock the mysteries of the
cosmos through a small telescope you'll
be able to be bonded with all the
astronomers throughout history you'll
become a universal voyager just like me
so parents any parents out there go out
there and buy a telescope for a kid in
your life or just get one for you you
can see the exact same objects galileo
saw 400 years ago even from the middle
of manhattan
you can see the craters on the moon the
rings of saturn the moons of jupiter the
faces of venus and millions of other
phenomena
one day i'll start my own keating brand
telescope company because i've probably
sold more telescopes to parents and
friends around the world that isaac
newton himself what's it gonna take to
get you into a keating brand star
spotter 2000 i'll include simonizing and
undercoating and i'll throw in these
wheeled tripods for free remember abc
always be curious or is it always be
closing basically take the telescope out
as soon as you get it read the
instructions put it together and point
it at the first bright object you see in
the sky but not the sun okay
that's my only disclaimer warning do not
look at the sun with your remaining eye
i want you to be able to watch my into
the impossible videos for decades to
come
so there you have it that's how i went
from a pimple face pudge ball to a
professor from a dweeb and dobbs ferry
to a star seeker at the south pole from
being a shy introverted pre-teen to
getting to hang out on captain kirk's
unexplained tv discussing the wonders of
the moon and it's all thanks to a tiny
little telescope that i got when i was a
kid many many decades ago and i hope you
will do the same for the child in your
life
i'll put some links to great telescopes
for any budget
on my blog at briankeating.com
just click here to access it leave a
comment in the comment section below
about how it felt when you or your child
first saw the craters on the moon
if you want to hear more about my
astronomical journey click here to see
my google talk or click here to see an
interview with some of my astronomy
buddies debating the greatest mysteries
in cosmology and astronomy today
[Music]